I love it good hustle good hustle yeah
for sure
hold on one second oh all right yeah so
Alex icon you can check me out Alex icon
we created luck see here 500 journal
productivity planner coming out so the
question for you is there is
business-related please as you know we
built something similar to you we've got
a sparked off yes yes so did the same
thing little bit a lot of jabs didn't a
lot of working at years now build
leverage we have build everage build the
trust your brand can have a substantial
business down to seven figures yep what
now that is bent over yours we kind of
stagnated yeah because to my question so
my question to you and I think there are
the weaknesses here is actually scaling
yes so because we try to do everything
ourselves we have a small team but how
do you actually build that with you a
most important questions that how do you
build and maintain that culture and add
that love that you the same love that
you have for the business in other
people other people this is a very is a
very Eastern European question is very
common things that so the answer is you
don't
if you expect somebody else to love your
business as much as you you two are out
of your mind and this is something I try
to teach my dad as a young kid oh my dad
you own the business how the hell do you
want them to love this as much as you
what you need to do is several different
things yeah first of all thank you for
asking me question I lived it I did it
at Wine Library from people that are
more like you
you guys went 2-0 to something just like
my pops and how I scaled it was I taught
him these pillars and I taught in these
pillars which is number one get over
that it's over they're never gonna love
it as much as you and if you're lucky
enough like I find like that amazing man
behind you if you can find people that
could love it
8.5 as much of a tent 9.2 as much of a
tent nine point seven on a Holy Grail
moment out of ten well then you've won
so that's never gonna happen and it's
actually completely completely
disrespectful for you to even want that
from somebody else because you never
loved somebody else's business as much
as you love your own so why you know try
to make somebody else - number one
number two the biggest mistake people
make at this point is you start wanting
to cash in on some of the fruits of this
amazing hard work it's a little bit more
exciting to dress a little bit better to
live in a better place to take a
vacation to do all he said I get it the
way to scale and grow is to have the
dollars to continue to scale and grow if
you're doing everything yourself there's
a couple reasons one you're
perfectionists and don't think anybody
else can do it - you see other people do
it they do it as an 8 - your 10 and
that's not good enough 3 you do not want
to deploy the money because you want to
use those monies for other things for
yourselves and other things all three
are massive bowler villains
fix those three and you'll grow I run my
businesses the first five ten years of
their lives at no profit and I did it
and people can say now easy for you
[ __ ] I was 28 years old
I built a humongous business and I was
making $40,000 a year my friends that
were half me and a hundredth of me
making more money had better cars we're
having more fun I was 28 years old
making $40,000 a year and I built a
thirty million dollar business of that
day that's eating your own dog so get
over yourselves and be thankful that
people want to work for you and get them
to an eight or nine and you get them to
an eight or nine by loving them more but
you did for your audience you need to do
for your employees employees ten times
more biggest mistake entrepreneurs make
they treat their employees worse than
they treat their customers biggest
mistake treat them better than you
treated your audience then they'll get
from a six to an eight and that's
amazing they'll never get to attack it's
not their business number two decide how
much you want to live great now versus
every dollar every dollar you take that
trip to Spain is three dollars less that
you make three years from now what if
you have substantial money after the
vacations after everything into poor
people but how do you find these people
who are still eight even there're seven
but easy because you need to treat them
better because you've got them you just
need to change the way you're treating
and if they don't get there after you
treat them way better you fire them and
you find people that do react to you
giving them more value than they're
providing do you understand yeah really
not fully not letting you go here's my
thing you kick it how many employees do
you guys have around the world
great you need to really vet them the
number one thing I would do if I were
you is I would call them right after the
show and say what can I do to make this
much better for you so we're good good
do you deliver on them yeah great
well then you should be having no
problem then then I'm a little bit more
confused then either you've not built
enough trust with them for them to tell
you the truth or you're just not hiring
fast and I think we're not hiring good
because um because we're trying to have
everybody be like fully ped so you know
we're like Eric Eric Eric was what
number play 1717 he watched Boehner go
from 17 to 200 then for personal reasons
he went the boss he's back now and we're
600 what Eric can tell you all the
vaynermedia employees from 70 to 200
stick with me year is not an insult
he knows how many four five six seven
and eight you need four or five six
seven eighths when you're big you can't
make seven tens that's how you scale and
win that's the secret it's not about you
guys getting seven people to attend it's
about you hiring 40 people at each
question so we're at six seven right now
it's four many visits were times I split
them up it's actually a question I
wanted to ask you for a long very long
time now that you needed that practice
gotta squash time okay so the question
is knowing you have a successful
business money in the bank yeah
everything's great
yes is this a slow growing every office
yeah but the thing is who would you who
would be your first five like you have
to say customer service hired
yes and one marketing person boat will
be your next five hire I'd have to look
at your business and understand so first
of all commerce so first of all I've
brought first and foremost I would
reverse engineer you to whatever you to
like doing the most and are the best at
I would surround the hires around that
I'd let you continue to do that
because a lot of people try to replace
the thing they're best at after the
mistake
stay doing what you do best that and
whatever the two of you collectively do
the weakest that's when you hire in
order five next people whether that's
finance HR product become technology
whatever they are but what's been your
most that's hire for you even in that
first kind of go in that white library
when you've scaled the best is one of
the best hires for you that's like the
best hires I've ever made have been the
friends that I've hired that's the big
secret to me but Tom position was
probably the financial people you know
like the CFO's the the leave financial
person have been the best hires because
they've given me a context to pay cuz
I'm so aggressive I want to spend every
dollar so that gives up vulnerability
the reason I've never gone out of
business is I'm so much better at
selling than everybody else in the world
I can always keep it float even against
my enormous investment i so i
vaynermedia I would say mark Young can
the water creating legal in house was a
huge hire Kelley an early managing
director because she created a lot of
context and then people that look like
Eric which were disproportionately
talented and open for to allow me to
mold because we were all playing a new
game people that are moldable but
talented are very attractive
cool